I I've talked a lot about how women in
2023 are completely different than women
of other Generations I don't even think
the stats are really fair to us I I
almost think they're too good I know you
I I think the 50% divorce rate will
increase I don't say this in a happy way
I don't say it because I'm happy about
it I think that social media has warped
women's Brains so badly that most women
are not even capable of being monogamous
and getting attention from one man
that's to damn man I I think women when
they start at 12 13 years old getting
attention from all of these guys online
I think it is damn near impossible for
them to be monogamous I I think it's
impossible a modern marriage is women
still getting attention from other men
but maybe being sexually exclusive to
her husband that's a modern marriage
I've come to this conclusion based on
interviews and also based on clips that
I've seen of women talking about this so
I saw this woman talking about her
attention addiction from Instagram would
you ever start an only and I was like
how me me I like how could you even ask
me that and he literally goes like you
post things that are basically like that
what do you have such judgment about it
for and I was sitting there like H and I
really took a step back I analyzed like
the things that I had been posting the
presentence that I had on social media
and at the time I was posting like seven
stories a day of myself I was so deep in
it and I had taken 3 days off of social
media not posting one story not posting
one photo of myself absolutely zero
attention and this is coming from
someone who I'm like I pride myself on
the fact that like I don't need male
attention I don't need attention from I
felt lonely not getting that attention I
can't even believe it I was not even
aware and I know this might sound so
silly to some people but when you're so
deep in it you have no idea the effect
that it's having even just the little
like hearts on social media that's like
a dopam mean hit that was a moment where
I I was like I have to change some
things stop it get some help that is
from a woman that's probably been on
social media since she was 12 13 some of
the kids even younger even younger it
warps your brain it makes you crazy you
know I I got social media in my teenage
years I was a little bit older now kids
are getting it at like s eight like kids
are growing up on iPad to the point
where 3 days off of social media I
actually think most women taking 3 days
off of social media would be crazy to
them I I think that's the norm not the
exception so how do these women go from
getting all of this attention to being
monogamous I I don't think it's likely I
think it's mostly impossible I think the
modern relationship is going to be the
best ones or the woman is sexually
exclusive but she will still receive
attention and validation from other men
you will still see women and and really
I don't even want to say you still see
it you see it now I I see wives and
mothers and that that's why I started
the hashtag em challenge because I these
conservative influencers would talk
about how conservative they are yet they
would be posting super sexual pictures
while married I I just couldn't even
believe it she belongs to the streets
okay now the comment section um weighs
in and the comment section you know
what's funny when women are are honest
and actually take a bit of
accountability men are men are actually
nicer than you would think so I applaud
her for coming to that realization a
large percentage of women will never
have this Epiphany another comment says
she's cluing in this is how Humanity
evolves don't shame her while it may
seem trivial to reach this type of
self-awareness it will spread because of
her status and how many girls will be
spared from The Hollow Path yeah I'm not
too I've just seen so many chicks maybe
maybe I've turned into a pessimist I
don't know guys sometimes I don't know
when you're kidding I've seen so many
chicks like walk away and then come back
and do the same thing it's just yeah
okay T Coy says I I hope she does I hope
she does though they love two things
attention and being blissfully unaware
of their actions yeah